[Music]
we've got a comic who's a very very dear
friend of mine and one of our staff
writers here on the show you may have
seen her on girl code and Chelsea Lately
please welcome one of my best friends
Jamie Lee everybody Jamie
[Applause]
yeah like a fun aunt with this necklace
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's kind of like it make my body look
divorced I'm getting back out there
right here on the Pete Home Show it's
gonna be here how are you guys you guys
drink you drink this
fuzzy Susie's okay I don't mean to judge
you if you do but I only drink when it's
a special occasion you know like when
it's someone's birthday on Facebook but
um I don't really like bars
I don't like bars because I feel like at
every bar there's always like that one
sort of creepy overconfident guy who
like swoops in and tries to talk to
women who want nothing to do with him
it's always the same guy - he's always
like 70 years old and he's got like a
cascading Grace XCOM you Hoani tail and
a lazy eye and a bolo tie just a hunk of
turquoise right on the clavicle like we
get it man you went to Santa Fe once in
98 he saddles up like hey little lady
what's your sign I'm like yield
[Applause]
they told away he doesn't get it he's
like that's cool that's cool I'm a
cancer I'm like oh yeah we know you're
rich cancer melanoma why don't you go
away sir I'm too literal for pickup
lines like once in college this guy was
like damn girl how you get all that ass
into them jeans I was like a shoehorn
and I ran away I think the weirdest
thing that was ever thrown my way once I
was at a bar and this guy came up to me
and my friends and this was his go-to
opening line he said hey does the carpet
match the drapes I don't know which is
which I feel like it warranted and
equally creepy response I was like nah
man I pulled up the carpet only the
original hardwood floors
I didn't stop there I didn't stop there
I kept going I was like yeah crazy you
know newly-renovated oh my god I got a
team of men to come in and yank out all
those staples and rusty nails from the
board's really got a sandpaper it out
give it a good buffering if you look in
the crawl space you'll find a bottle of
moonshine in my diary
so crazy put a fresh coat of paint on it
go crazy fresh coat of paint but if the
paint's wet don't let the dog like it or
old die
now buy me a drink you sexy beast so fun
fact about me I'm half-jewish I am I'm
half-jewish I guess it just means I've
like a conflicted outlook on life like I
see the glass like half you know smashed
or whatever the top smashed its marked
down no I
I hate that stereotype I hate that I
hate the people thing like Jews are
cheap and we love a good sale so
annoying this is like come on all the
clothes I'm wearing right now I bought
full price thank you so just get a good
look before I return them all that
garbage dump I go to Marshalls it's
cheaper now I'm in a good place right
now I was single for a while single for
a long long long while you know I like
that kind of single win it's not like
empowering like carry single it's like
kill me single you know you're just like
scratching it yourself in the mirror
like I think I need a man now just like
start to sound like Nancy Grace after a
plan there's no good reason but I don't
know I didn't my ex-boyfriend I never
really felt comfortable staying at my
ex-boyfriends apartment cuz it was one
of these situations where he had a dog
and the dog would just like always stare
at us like while we were having sex with
it
[Applause]
the worst right it's like turn around
you know like isn't that supposed to be
your style like like didn't your friends
coin that one you know like why are we
missionary you're a pug but it was hard
it was really hard no the reason my
single experience was so tough was
because while I was single I was also on
the drug accutane do you guys know that
drug it's a very severe acne medication
with lots of severe side effects but the
funny thing is on the side of the box
they list the severe side effects inside
a long list of really dumb one so it
literally says like may cause dry lips
suicidal thoughts crankiness and you're
like hold up suicidal thought you can't
stand what you get glazed over that
you've never entered into a relationship
if it was like someone does spend Friday
nights with has AIDS makes him mean that
would be tough though because I'd be
like I do love pasta the hardest thing
about it was I I I was a catch-22 I went
on the drugs I was like I want my skin
to clear up so I feel confident on dates
but hey guys it's hard to feel confident
on a date when you want to kill yourself
it's a little tricky the guy's trying to
have normal first date banter he's like
so what are you into and I'm like oh you
know just like every girl I just love
like long walks on the beach just right
into the water with all my clothes on at
about 11 p.m. when no one can rescue me
I have a cat in my purse come back to my
place I'll let you stick it in and buy
it I mean my Steel Magnolias DVD right
into the DVD player I love to cry all
the time
just kidding it's already in the DVD
player thank you I wanna I want to get
married you guys I really do I want to
get married but I'm afraid of marriage
because I'm afraid of divorce you know
it's like what if we never get one
[Applause]
[Music]